Thank you.
[Silence]
Continuing in Al Wajeez
Continuing in Al Wajeez in the book of
fasting in the chapter regarding the
days in which it is prohibited for a
person to fast. So far, we have
mentioned four
days or four
instances where it is impermissible for
a person to fast. Let's see if we can
review them.
The first
is
eight. So,
the first of Shawwal and the 10th of
Dhu al-Hijjah. The second
Okay.
We're getting all of them at once.
the days of Tashreeq, right? So,
11th, 12th, 13th of Dhul-Hijjah. Then we
had al-Jumu' on its own, isolated. And
then the fourth one is
Saturday on its own. Okay.
Now, we said this applies only to
optional fasting, right? If a person
for instance, were to have a day of
Ramadan to finish, to make up,
right? And you know, their day off
happens to be a Saturday or happens to
be a Friday. Would it be permissible for
that person to make that day up on that
day?
Yes, because it's not an optional
fasting, it's an obligatory fasting,
right?
Okay, the fifth one that the author
mentions here is an-nisf min Sha'ban
The second half of Sha'ban
for a person who isn't
who isn't accustomed to fasting
at a particular pattern. So,
the second half of Sha'ban. Sha'ban is
the eighth month.
And it is the month just before Ramadan.
15 days before Ramadan or
14 days, once a person hits the 15th
of Sha'ban,
it becomes impermissible for a person to
fast
unless they are accustomed to fasting
on a particular schedule. Let's say
someone usually fasts Mondays and
Thursdays. Or a person usually fasts
you know, every other day. Or a person
usually fasts This person can continue
his fast.
The only one who is prohibited or the
optional fasting which is prohibited at
the second half of Shaban is the one who
is trying to gear up for Ramadan. They
don't have a particular
schedule that they
adhere to. It's just that Ramadan is
approaching so they begin to fast early.
This is impermissible. It is not
permissible to fast after the second
or during the second half of Shaban.
He says
on the authority of Abu Hurairah who
narrates that the messenger of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
said
if the second half of Shaban commences,
then do not fast. If the second half
of Shaban commences, do not fast.
[Silence]
Also on the authority of Abu Hurairah
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
said
none of you is to fast
a day or two before Ramadan begins
unless it is someone who has a
particular schedule or pattern that they
fast upon throughout the year, then you
may adhere to that schedule.
Now, this narration is more akin
to
the
next prohibition, or the next
prohibited time of fasting.
So, we have the second half of Sha'ban.
And then, the sixth that the author
mentions is Yawm al-Shakk.
The the day of the doubted day, the
day of doubt. What is the day of doubt?
What is Yawm al-Shakk? Yawm al-Shakk is
when we are looking for the moon
for Ramadan. We are looking for the
crescent for Ramadan.
Ramadan, the crescent may be today, may
be tomorrow, right?
is is Ramadan going to be
tomorrow? Very likely Ramadan will be
tomorrow, but we haven't seen the moon
yet, so therefore, we are unsure if
Ramadan is tomorrow or not. Let me go
ahead and fast it just to be safe. This
is a prohibited time of fasting, and
this is
positively prohibited in the
following narration.
[Silence]
He says, "On the authority of Ammar ibn
Yasir, who narrates,
or who says,
'Whoever fasts on the day which is
on the dubious day, the day of doubt,
the dubious day, then this person has
this person has disobeyed Abu al-Qasim.
Abu al-Qasim is the prophet sal Allah
who alayhi wasallam. That was his kunya.
So,
here Ammar ibn Yasir is telling us that
if a person fasts on that day
in which the moon has not been sighted,
but it could have likely been sighted,
but we're unsure, there is shak there.
Ramadan has either started or it has
not.
And we mentioned that this all pours
into the general rule that is the month
the crescent
is the crescent the month of any any
month? That's the question. Is the
crescent
the actual month?
All right.
Faisal remembers because we discussed
this
day or two before Ramadan started.
Right?
Now it feels a thousand years ago,
but
if you remember back
before Ramadan started this year
we discussed the moon sighting rulings.
And one of the things that we One of the
conclusions that we arrived at is that
the crescent is not the month.
What is the month?
You remember?
The cycle A moon is the indication.
It is the sign of the month. But the
actual month is what? 29 or 30 days. No.
Ijtima' al-nas. Yeah. Ash-shahru min
al-ishtihar.
All right. Ash-shahru
is from
is taken from even the the the word
itself is taken from something that is
public.
And so a shahada even by its
actual name articulates the meaning of
public. When it becomes publicly
acknowledged, that is the month.
The month is the acknowledgement of the
majority of people,
not the crescent. The crescent is not
the month.
Okay?
Very easy for you to remember. A shahada
a shahada
my name Mashhur, right? Mashhur
public, well-known, right? That is
what the word shahada is taken from.
It's taken from that same root
meaning, which is something becoming
well-known, becoming public, becoming
accepted, becoming
widely acknowledged. This is called a
shahada.
So a shahada
is commenced
either by
exactly 30 days going by
to where it can no longer possibly be
the previous month anymore.
Or number two,
the acknowledgement of the majority of
people.
It is not the crescent. The crescent is
an indicator
for the month.
Therefore, when we look and we are
looking for the crescent and we say,
"Well, it could have been seen, maybe it
was seen. I didn't see it, but perhaps
and it's cloudy and the
last night the clouds were out and there
was overcast and the the you know, the
crescent could have been there. We just
weren't able to see it."
It doesn't matter if the crescent was
there or not. As a matter of fact, it
doesn't matter if the crescent was seen
by even one person unless
we have widespread acknowledgement of
the month or 30 days have been completed
of the previous month
the month has not started yet.
The month has not started yet. So, there
is no day of doubt really. There is no
doubt. It either is or it is not
Ramadan. There is no maybe it's Ramadan,
but we don't know that it's Ramadan. So,
Ramadan is actually happening somewhere,
but we have no idea that it's happening.
This doesn't exist. This is a
hypothetical that is non-existent.
Therefore, the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam positively prohibited that a
person fast during what? During the day
that is referred to as Yawm ash-Shakk.
Which is the 30th day
which falls between two months. It could
either be the 30th day
or it could be the first day. This day
is referred to as what day? Yawm
ash-Shakk. Right? And there is no such
thing as a doubtful
month commencing. It either is or it
isn't the month.
Even if the crescent was obscured or
overcast or what have you, right? This
is a very important point and if many
people if many of the Muslimeen actually
understood this point in America for
instance much of the differing that we
have would what? Would would disappear.
All right? Cuz the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says
As-sawmu yawma tasumun wal-fitru
[Arabic recitation]
chapter or for the whole book.
What do you think? Should we continue in
this book or revert back to Riyadh
as-Salihin?
We could start back at the book of
Salah.
Huh?
You think we should continue?
That's your opinion?
Okay.
Well, thank you for that.
Maybe we will continue.
We'll see.